The one piece manga just set up the biggest
challenge for Luffy and co in the story so
far. As the crew is getting ready to leave the
laboratory on egg head island together with their
newest crew member Dr. Vegapunk, admiral Kizaru
is about to arrive at the island with a massive
fleet of Marine war ships. And the narrator
says: 迫る、海軍本部最高戦力。。。Which literally means ‘The
Marine Haeadquarter’s ultimate military power is
approaching’. And this could mean that we finally
get to see an admiral go all out for the very
first time in the story. That would mean that
we finally see how strong the admirals truly are
and if the straw hats are powerful enough to take
on the strongest people in the Marines. But you
might be wondering, how did Kizaru get here so
fast? Well as soon as Kizaru heard about the
straw hats being on the island, he immediately
put one and one together and figured out that
the straw hats would try and rescue Vegapunk
from the special agents sent by the government
to assassinate him. I think it’s very easy to
underestimate Kizaru. he always looks like he
is the least motivated of all the admirals,
who doesn’t take anything seriously. However
this couldn’t be further from the truth. We
have seen it many many times now, that Kizaru is
actually the most active out of all the marine
admirals we have seen so far. Greenbull seems
to enjoy lying around and immediately retreated
from Wano once he couldn’t easily dominate his
opponents anymore. Both Aokiji and Fujitora are
always very careful in their actions, taking
circumstances and the people around them into
account. And even Akainu is surprisingly
passive in his leadership. For instance,
he refuses to attack Wano, carefully considering
the Marine’s power and what a battle would mean
for their forces. Kizaru is the only admiral
who is always eager to jump right into action.
We have seen Akainu holding him back a number
of times now. Remember Kizaru was willing to
go to Wano on his own and face 3 Yonko’s
at once. That takes some serious balls.
And i actually want to explain
all the marine admirals in detail,
so I will make a dedicated video about that, if
at least 1000 people subscribe until tomorrow.
But going back to Kizaru, did you also notice
that he is clearly not really eager to take orders
from Akainu? Because while Akainu is getting
briefed on the situation with Luffy and Lucci,
he only then realizes that Vegapunk knew
about the government’s plan to kill him.
Meanwhile Kizaru had not only gotten that
information before the fleet admiral,
but also already left with an entire army
without waiting for Akainu’s permission.
And the manga literally says in Japanese: ‘The
Marine Haeadquarter’s ultimate military power is
approaching’. Does Oda mean an admiral? Or does
he mean Kizaru specifically? Because it would be
truly a bombshell if the strongest marine fighter
would turn out to be neither Akainu nor Aokiji,
who both fought for the position of fleet
admiral, but actually Kizaru all along. Kizaru
himself at least seems to be quite confident
that he can stop the straw hats himself,
either with sheer strength or he has something
up his sleeve that he’s bringing with him.
So, will Luffy actually fight Kizaru? Will
we finally find out how strong an admiral
is at full strength? It’s possible. I think
there are 3 ways this could go: Option 1:
Kizaru is about to attack the straw hats and
Vegapunk, but someone rescues the straw hats
and allows them to get away. I think this
scenario is actually pretty likely. For one,
we now have Vegapunk with the crew and i would
be really surprised, if he didn’t have a bunch
of tricks up his sleeve in his own laboratory,
that would allow the crew to escape the incoming
fleet of warships. On top of that, you might
remember, that Kuma has started running away
from the revolutionaries and has most likely
teleported himself towards where Luffy and his
daughter Bonney are. Because that happened exactly
the moment, when Vegapunk realized that the agents
of CP0 had infiltrated the island. So he could be
the one to safe the crew once again from Kizaru,
like he did on Sabaody archipelago. Also by the
way, there are a lot of parallels with sabaody
and enis lobby during this arc. Cyborg Franky
vs cyborg vegapunk. The Ohara flashback during
enies lobby and the ohara flashback here. Lucci
vs Luffy. Sentomaru, Kizaru and Kuma vs the straw
hats. This time Sentomaru, Kuma and the straw
hats against Kizaru. And there is also a real
chance that the revolutionary army might show
up again as well. After all, Dragon was chasing
after Kuma trying to stop him from leaving again.
So the straw hats might just be able to escape
another time, and we’ll have to wait for their
battle against all the admirals for a bit longer.
Option 2 here, is much less likely, but
my personal favorite. Since the crew is
about to set sail and Kizaru is coming with
a fleet of ships, there’s a chance that we
might get to see the first sea battle in the
history of one piece. I know it sounds crazy,
but even though one piece is a story about pirates
and marines sailing the giant oceans of the world,
we haven’t had a single real sea battle in the
entire story. The most we have gotten was the crew
being chased around, like on whole cake island.
So it would be truly refreshing to see some actual
ship vs ship battle for a change, which would
also give franky a real chance to show off his
technology to Vegapunk. This would of course also
be a great opportunity for the straw hat grand
fleet to arrive. Imagine the thousand sunny all
along facing a whole armada of marine war ships
and then suddenly ships appearing behind them
on the horizon. It would also be a great chance
to bring Harujin and his Giant crew into the
story again to guide the straw hats to Elbaf,
which is most likely the next destination after
this. I don’t know how the fleet would know about
the straw hat’s dangerous situation here, but
it would be truly awesome to see nonetheless.
But option number 3 would be even better. And
that’s, that the straw hats actually have a all
out battle with Kizaru and the other Marines. Now
it’s really hard to say how powerful Kizaru really
is and if Luffy would be able to defeat him. Is
Kizaru stronger than Kaido? It seems unlikely,
but then again, he was more than
eager to go to Wano and fight him,
Luffy and Big Mom. So who knows. But even if he
is a bit weaker than Kaido, Luffy has just used
his gear5 form in his fight with Lucci. nd yes
he has successfully beaten Lucci a second time,
and even though Lucci clearly has become very
powerful himself, he couldn’t even touch Luffy.
But we also see that Luffy has turned into that
old man form again after using his awakening.
Clearly gear 5 is draining Luffy of his energy
and I’m not sure if he would be able to simply
reactivate it again if Kizaru popped up. However
all the other straw hats are well rested. Zoro and
Sanji definitely could put up a real fight this
time. And on top of that, we have also seen a pair
of gloves in Vegapunk’s lab that makes it possible
to touch light. Plus an actual light saber that
Bonney picked up. So, it does seem like Oda has
set up a fight with admiral Kizaru for SOMEBODY.
But on top of this epic set up for Kizaru and
his grand armada, we also had some other major
stuff happening: Luffy’s battle with Lucci
was absolutely epic and really fun to read,
we got a bunch of new gear 5 attacks and a ton
of references to their first fight during enies
lobby. Some of the panels were designed in the
exact same way, like this one from last chapter,
and this time Lucci also thinks to himself that
his consciousness is fading, just like on enis
lobby. I think the fight was more something to
just enjoy. Not really to discuss in depth here.
I really liked that Lucci was super strong and
didn’t go down right away, but still couldn’t
lay a finger on Luffy, who now finally gets the
respect a Yonko deserves. The biggest takeaway of
the fight, is that the 3 seraphim who were
in the lab have now also gone over to the
government’s side. Though it was really nice
seeing them fight as an ally here for a bit.
I also really like that the seraphim can actually
talk and have some real personality too. That not
only makes them terrifying weapons, but actual
characters that can be talked to and interacted
with. It might well be that Luffy will free them
from the government control too at some point. Or
maybe vegapunk has secretly inserted Dragon as
their supreme commander on top of the Gorosei.
And then we also had even more lore drop on
Vegapunk’s aritificial devil fruits. He confirms,
that different categories of devil fruits
are differently easy or hard to copy. Zoans,
as we already guessed are the easiest, because
they are literally based on animals. Paramecia
fruits require dna from the user, which is
known as the lineage factor in one piece.
And logia fruit users are basically impossible to
copy. They just really like being the most unique
category of furuits huh. This of course explains
why the jinbei seraphim has the swim swim fruit,
after Doflamingo and his crew were captured by
the marines. It’s very likely there is a dofi
seraphim with his string fruit powers
as well. And it might also explain,
why shanks insisted on taking ace’s and
whitebeards body away from marineford. To
keep the government from stealing his power’s too.
If anyone knows about this, it’s shanks after all.
And speaking of the linage factor and devil
fruit experiments, we have to talk about the
cover of this chapter too, where we see young
versions of doctor vegapunk, a slim queen, an
emo ceasar and a really quirky looking judge. Love
these designs. But it stood out to me that judge
doesn’T have sanji’s spirally eyebrows, nor does
his mother. So the idea that sanji has received
some sort of devil fruit ability from the lineage
factor experiments on him seems to have gotten a
bit more proof. That’s because his eyebrow has
the same spiral shape as those on devil fruits.
We have gotten so much knowledge on devil fruits
and their awakening these last few chapters,
that as promised, i have condensed
everything we know into this video,
if you would like to get an overview.
Thanks so much for watching.